peak performance yes that is the title
of apple's upcoming march 8th event and
mark german was right he no longer needs
to shave his eyebrows like john prosser
was posting just kidding he never said
he would do that but he has been
redeemed he was right the entire time
and we are so relieved because we've had
an apple tech drought for the last three
months making all these leak videos
we're finally back to getting some real
apple products but the craziest thing
about all of this is the title peak
performance which has some major
major hints for what we should be seeing
at this upcoming event alongside with
some brand new leaks that we just got
over the last couple of days in terms of
what we should expect so before i get
into all of that i want to get into the
products that we knew were going to be
coming and talking about the specs and
features that we should expect for those
new products first of all we were
expecting a new iphone se for months and
months now and it's basically gonna be
the iphone se3 and it's not gonna have a
new redesign which is very disappointing
according to ross young who says it's
gonna have the same old 4.7 inch display
yes with the same home button with touch
id which really really sucks but
according to mark german he says that
this could actually be a big deal
because apple is likely to lower the
price way down and make it basically the
best deal on an iphone ever which could
be pretty great as well as apple adding
5g and the new a15 bionic chip which
will make it incredibly snappy but to me
i just can't go with that old design it
is just so outdated compared to all the
new android budget phones that are
coming out with the new oled displays
the full designs with the hole punch
without the square display with the home
button honestly i don't think it's going
to be a top seller and i don't think
it's going to be a big deal at all but
we are sure that that is coming because
we just started getting some new leaks
first of all from match and boo showing
off some new cases and accessories that
are rumored to be launching on march
10th exactly two days after the march
8th event and i fully believe that we
are going to see that now after that we
already knew that we were getting a new
ipad air and we knew this for sure
because of apple's update cycles around
one and a half years between each ipad
air for the last couple of years so it
had to come out right now because as you
know the ipad air is way behind in terms
of the specs and features compared to
the new ipad mini 6 which came out last
fall and that ipad has access to 5g as
well as the new a15 bionic chip and
other features like the ultra wide 12
megapixel selfie camera which the ipad
air still does not have even though the
new budget ipad has that for only 329
so i can guarantee you that the ipad air
5 is coming at this next event on march
8th and in terms of some of the extra
features that we should expect on that
ipad air we're likely to get quad stereo
speakers as well as a new square-ish
camera bump just like we have on the
ipad pro except that it's only going to
have two cameras probably without the
lidar and the main reason for apple to
give the square bump to the ipad air is
because it supports the magic keyboard
and currently the magic keyboard has a
square cutout
and it looks really weird with the ipad
air having just a single camera bump so
i fully believe apple is going to be
adding that new square camera bump to
the ipad air but other than that we
shouldn't be expecting too many new
features i think it's just going to be a
pretty simple update and it's going to
have the regular lcd display no oled no
mini led and no pro motion 120 hertz
technology like the ipad pro currently
has and now on top of the new iphone se3
and the ipad air we're probably gonna
get a new color or finish for the iphone
13 so it's just going to be a nice
little spring update no changes there
just a new color for the current iphone
and now with all that said let's get
into the most exciting and most
important part of this entire event and
this new invitation which is titled peak
performance the big point that you need
to realize is that the ipad air and the
iphone sc are not going to get any
changes to performance at all they're
going to be getting the older chips so
if apple says peak performance that
means they are unveiling something
brand new
yes that means they're gonna unveil a
brand new chip
and we have been seeing a lot of rumors
that we should be seeing some new macs
so first of all potentially two desktop
macs and one
macbook according to the eec filings so
we should be expecting that and in terms
of which products first of all we think
it'll for sure be an m1 pro m1 max mac
mini with a new design but then
potentially either a new imac or a new
m2 mac mini yes m2 chip the brand new
empty chip as well as potentially an m2
macbook pro because we've seen many many
leaks about a new macbook pro coming at
this event even though it doesn't make
any sense at all like when digitimes
said it was coming and we all laughed at
them because they have a bad track
record i think it is actually coming
because we just seen so many leaks mark
german digit times other sources and
especially the eec filing i think it's
coming for sure and that is why apple is
calling it peak performance yes the new
m2 chip is likely to be revealed and now
as i'm checking my twitter for some
extra leaks while filming this video i
just got a tweet from dan roy which
basically back on the 22nd of last month
he posted a leak for march 8 2022 an
apple event with an iphone se ipad air
and a macbook pro so really guys i think
we're going to be seeing a new macbook
pro and unfortunately mark german said
that it's going to have a 13 inch
display it's not going to be 14 inch
like the current uh 2 000 macbook pro
that we have but he says it's going to
have the old design without a touch bar
and that sounds really weird for apple
to do but in my opinion if they're gonna
be trying to squeeze out another macbook
pro with the old design it makes sense
to do so right now and then about six
months later in the fall they're gonna
release the new redesigned macbook air
so they're gonna give this old macbook
pro style or design six months to try to
get as much sales as possible so that's
very interesting that apple's gonna go
with that route but i think it's
actually gonna happen and i'm just so
excited to see that m2 chip but with all
that said guys let me wrap up exactly
what to expect we'll definitely get the
iphone se we'll definitely get the ipad
air we might get a new color for the
iphone as well as a lot of new spring
cases for the iphone 13 and we're likely
to get a couple of macs at least
definitely a high-end mac mini and
probably a new macbook pro and that
extra mac i'm not sure what it's going
to be but it might be an m2 mac mini so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you're as excited as i am for
this new march 8th event click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video